How to not be boring in a conversation? That
would be a good thing not to be. I'm Chad. I'm
the co-author of Ask Powerful Questions Create
Conversations That Matter. And in this video,
we're going to talk about how to not be
boring in conversation. Let's get into it.
In this video, I'm going to unpack a couple
strategies that I use personally to have
really meaningful conversations. And the first
framework and the biggest idea in all of this
is the age-old concept that it's more important to
be interested than interesting. And that requires
a shift from focusing on this person to focusing
on the other person. And so, it's the reason that
the title of our book is Ask Powerful Questions
not make really interesting statements. That said,
questions are good questions invite us to connect
with other people. Questions tell others that
we're interested in them and we don't want to
just talk about ourselves. However, a conversation
without self-disclosure is actually an
interrogation, right? And so, oddly enough in this
video, I'm going to offer some ideas that don't
lean just on asking questions. Because I wrote
a whole book about that. And if you're interested
it's been on Amazon sitting as a best seller for
quite a while. And so you can google Ask Powerful
Questions. Find that and there's a whole bunch of
really great strategies on how to not have boring
meetings. In this video, I want to unpack the
the sequel to the book that we never wrote
which is how to tell really intriguing stories.
And so, if you've got that me to we shift down
and you're focused on the other and you're not
so worried about coming across as interesting,
it can be really impactful to tell stories that
people want to hear. I once met a woman who was
about half my height and introduced herself as a
professional storyteller. And I asked her, "What
is the number one tip you could give me to tell
really powerful stories?" And she looked at me and
just really simply and calmly responded and said,
"All you need to do is know the first
sentence that you're going to say
and the last sentence that you're going to say."
And so, I didn't actually realize this until I
started working with individuals and companies
on how to create conversations that really matter
and make connection and engagement really easy. I
didn't realize this that one of the things I do if
I know an event is coming up or I know something's
coming up, I think about who are these people?
What do they care about? And sometimes I think of
my opening line if you will when you walk in. And
that feels a little like staged or something.
But I would argue that it's intentional.
So, often we show up without any sort of plan
whatsoever and we just hope that things go well.
And yet, in anything else in life, we plan things
out, right? If we want it to go really well,
we plan things out. We don't just have a wedding
on a whim. You plan it, you book a venue,
you make some intentional decisions to be able
to connect people. I would say the same is true
in conversation. Ideally, you are thinking about
the other person and thinking about "How can I
engage this person beforehand? How can I engage
this group beforehand?" So, know the first story
and the last story. The other thing is when
I was writing um my thesis in grad school,
I had a mentor that advised me to use the
notecard method. And this really simply was
get all your points put them on note
cards. Only one point per note card.
Don't worry about writing anything. Don't open up
a word document. No typing whatsoever. Handwrite
a bunch of ideas on a notecard one idea per note
card. And then, once you've got a whole bunch of
these, then arrange the order. Lay them all
out, map them out. Put them in order and then
write your thesis. And I'd say a conversation
might be similar. And so, to have to actually
create a bank of stories of questions
you like to ask of topics and actually
write them out on a notecard and create a
little deck for yourself so that you have
things that are cued up. And so, you're not
also telling the same story over and over and
over again to your family your friends, etc.
So, just an interesting strategy to sort of
map the filing cabinet of the lifetime of
experiences that exist in the back of your
brain. Hopefully, this video was useful. I hope
that you can now have conversations that are
slightly less boring. If you want one other really
brilliant tip, in the link in the description,
we give away the first chapter of Ask
Powerful Questions for free. It's a remarkable
tool to have conversations that skip beyond small
talk that end up uh diving really deep and taking
you down some rabbit holes you would never
otherwise experience. And when you're trying
to have a conversation that's not boring,
that is really useful. Have an awesome day.